[Music]
so when I was growing up as a young girl
in Wisconsin actually I was 10 years old
when Carl Sagan's show cosmos came on
Public Broadcasting and as a 10 year old
kind of we're living in rural Wisconsin
I had never really met an astronomer
that's not something you routinely meet
whenever people tell me you know you
don't really seem like an astronomer
that the wonderful next thing to ask is
how many stars do you know so you know
my vision of what an astronomer was was
this man on this television show on
public television Carl Sagan and the
thing that Carl did better than anybody
else I'd ever seen was this emotional
connection to the science he loved to
tell stories had tell stories about the
history but also you know it was from
him that I learned where all of the
atoms in my body come from the fact they
were all formed in stars and when Carl
talks about that on the show I mean we
sort of made a joke that there are these
things called Carl moments or Carl sort
of gazes dramatically off into space and
the camera sort of closes close up on
his face and you can see him sort of
moding at how wonderful this is and you
know these days you know decades later
this the scenes seem a little bit silly
and a little bit contrived but as a
child I was taken along for this
incredible emotional journey Carl was a
real rock star
he had this charisma and people would
just listen to what he was saying and
they would love to follow along with his
stories and that became to me the image
of what a scientist was what an
astronomer was was somebody that could
tell the stories of the universe so I I
never ended up meeting Carl I always
wanted to he unfortunately died very
young when he died in his early sixties
and I was a graduate student at the time
I always figured I would see him at some
astronomy conference I'd somehow you
know wander past him at one of these
scientific meetings and tell him how
much that his his show had meant to me
but I never got that chance I am I never
left though that idea that what a
scientist really does is tell stories
it's about the narrative it's about the
emotions and Carl did that better than
anyone I've ever seen
[Music]